[Music]
okay so this is my
spoiler review of the highly anticipated
new horror film
relic this has some big names behind it
it's executive produced by the russo
brothers famous for
doing the avengers franchise it is also
produced by jake gyllenhaal
and it's a directorial debut for natalie
erica james and it's also
a writing debut for her for a feature
film which she also writes with
christian white here so what i really
appreciate about
the beginning of this film is that a lot
of horror movies take their time to even
introduce
the fear of something going on the
feeling of suspense
to actually feel like a horror movie
there's usually about 20 minutes in a
lot of these type of films where you
don't even get that feeling yet
and then it gets to it but this opens up
with a whole sequence that happened last
christmas
with the grandma and you're wondering
already what's going on you're already
on edge
you see this tub is overflowing you see
that the lights are flickering
and there's really cool editing here and
this choice to have this like transition
where
shots are just flickering in and out
just like these lights and you see it
later on in the film as well
i thought that was really effective and
they also don't overdo
anything with the score there's barely a
score here
they do it more with sounds carrying the
way which was really cool in the
creaking of the house
and i think it could have been ruined if
they did the over
done crazy horror violin we're seeing so
much of they left that out and it was
for good reason
natalie erica james is already showing
she knows how to use silence to scare
you
and i think that's what works so well in
this whole movie is
no matter what part of the movie you're
in i would say about 80 of the film
you're on high alert thinking
something's gonna pop out and maybe it
doesn't
but you still had that suspense there so
that is effective in its own right but
where does the movie really shine it
really
shines thematically and it shines in the
story of having
three women in the same family but the
different generation
of the woman so you got the grandma you
got the mom and then you got the
daughter
and they're all played brilliantly by
their respective actresses
and i think that's also attributing to
how well they've been cast
i think it was so important to have
someone like bella heathcote play sam
because it had to be someone with a
youthful face and some
naive energy coming on from her she
almost kind of plays a little bit
like alice from alice in wonderland and
you see that when she literally
towards the exciting end sequence goes
down the rabbit hole of this house
i think they did that really well with
the casting so props to the casting team
and when i'm talking about thematically
having the grandma
have dementia but this be a story in the
horror aspect
about this cursed evil spirit
that is possessing the grandma is in
this house through this window
from the outhouse that used to be
outside on the property that's brought
this
black mold and curse into the house it's
really just
symbolic of the decay we all eventually
face and
really bleak in the sense just about
death and losing our minds and we're all
going that way
and it's like death is knocking on the
younger two
female characters here's dor and
literally you see
in the beginning of this movie they
first hear knocking in the house
and it's right over that mantle place
they eventually come out of
i'm guessing that's hinting this was
during the time when the grandma was
missing
she was definitely just in the house and
that was her knocking and she was going
through her own little rabbit hole
so i thought that was really cool and
again it's symbolic of that this is
going to come towards them in the end at
some point
and what's interesting too here with k
the mother
brilliantly played by emily mortimer in
such a reserved betrayal she does that
so well never over does anything
emotionally
and she has these interesting nightmare
sequences where she's thinking about
this outhouse
they only do it twice in the film but
first it shows you her
which we can assume the great grandpa
who started living this outhouse
and got cursed from this decay in it and
now we see the black mold filling up in
the second nightmare sequence
with her mother and seeing that and the
door kind of
just inviting her in that she'll
eventually go to that place
in a sense and i think that was
interesting because
it shows you that her growing up in that
house
she already had premonitions of this
fate they all were gonna face and that's
shown in the sketchbook she shows
of her dad where he drew the outhouse
but he also drew his daughter having
nightmares
so she already had premonitions from
being there and already in a sense had a
little bit of this curse
and will come full circle at the end
which we'll get to i think it was a
really smart decision
to not go into the backstories
of sam and kay i don't think it was
necessary and i think it was smart they
left that out
it doesn't actually serve the purpose of
the theme we didn't need to know
about their other lives outside of this
main story with the grandma so i think
that was a really smart decision
writing-wise and they really hit well on
this
tough decision-making we all face as we
get older with our parents and they get
more sick and you have them most of them
never wanting to go into the old home
and they almost look at his betrayal if
you try to get them there
so you don't know what to do because you
think it's the right thing for them but
they might hold a grudge against you
so you're like do i take them on or is
that not fair to myself and you see the
character of k
is facing that constantly where it works
like i said having character like sam
was a little more naive about it and
just hopeful and thinking for the best
for her grandma i'm like
i'll live with you but maybe not
realizing how detrimental that would be
to herself
and that she's got this positive energy
where maybe
k is a little more ground in reality
about the whole thing and how
far down the road her mother already is
and
i think that it's so powerful just
little emotional beats in this movie
where she goes to visit
the old people home and then she cries
in the car about it it's just that
feeling i think a lot of people can
relate to and it
gets you relating to this movie and
watching
the person who birthed you and raised
you like
sam says or you switched the role where
they changed your diapers now you're
changing their diapers but
the sadness we all feel watching them
kind of decay in their own right
and where does the horror come it plays
on the fear of the thoughts of
us realizing we're going to get there
one day that's going to be us soon
so that's where the horror truly shines
in this film and i believe was the goal
of this film is playing on that fear
and i think that's what makes it
effective and creepy is if you have a
life experience in that kind of terror
about thinking about
watching someone older you get sick and
that you'll get there
yeah you'll feel it in this movie and
when i'm talking about scenes where
you're on high alert
and let's say if we were in movie
theaters unfortunately really not seeing
this
yet because of corona but in the time
being i
imagine if i was in a theater scenes
especially where
she's like can you look under the bed
for me and she's about to look under the
bed i was terrified that's a scene i
would literally would have spilled my
popcorn
and then you kind of wonder too this
this decayed figure running through the
house you know
is it the grandma's husband is he
just had this experience before the
grandma's had it i wonder
you wonder who that exactly is or if
it's just an evil spirit
and another great scene playing on that
horror
scare you spill your drink moment is
just the washing machine spinning out of
control which we've all
experienced at late at night but they
brilliantly had it hold for a second
when she turns it off and then it slams
in the background
that worked well and again shows you how
well natalie the director is playing
with sound to scare you
now the one scene i thought was just
totally out of place it wasn't in sync
or rhythm with the whole movie and i
thought it was completely unnecessary
was the scene where we have this little
story going on where
jamie the next door neighbor we don't
know why
he wasn't allowed hanging out with
grandma anymore
but the way we get the reveal is that
sam goes and asks his dad
the whole dialogue of that scene is her
just getting an answer from the dad of
why that is
i think he could have just answered that
about what happened to jamie
way better it doesn't fit with how they
answer everything else in the film it
was just
a rare blotch of just bad
and a really good movie otherwise i'm
just shocked because it just doesn't
seem like
this director would even want a scene
like that in it i don't know if it's for
budget reasons who knows but
i think that it wasn't well thought out
so
maybe a better way to approach the
jamie's storyline of why he wasn't there
was
you could have just when sam first sees
jamie and meets him out
and sees him outside and we meet him for
the first time as the audience maybe
just give him like a hat he wears it's
very
recognizable because then you got this
whole sequence here
where you have all these opportunities
where sam's going down the rabbit hole
seeing all the black mold or getting
answers
she could have just found in like a trap
door room oh
the hat that maybe jamie wore and it
would explain that he was trapped there
at some point
i think that would have just been a more
not on the nose feeding you an answer
in dialogue like it did in the scene
with the dad so where the movie starts
to shine
is really in these scenes where they let
emily mortimer
really just bring it and she does it
here with the grandma where the
grandma's burying the old picture book
outside her mom's saying to her like
this thing this spear wants to get me
while i'm weak while i'm alone
and you see the guilt start to be
addressed now and being a daughter of a
sick
mom now and kay says that she wishes she
spent more time with her
and now she's come around and says she
could stay with her and she's sorry she
wasn't there more so it's a really
powerful scene an important
to set up the last scene and have its
emotional payoff and what's cool is
where you might have felt this was all
slow burn up to this point they
perfectly set up that the last half
hours where they ramp up
the actual suspense and action of the
movie because then we go into
like i said sam going down the rabbit
hole she's discovering that this is a
bigger house
than you would think on the surface and
this is actually hinted at in a couple
scenes before because
there's literally a line where the
grandma says it feels like since my
husband died the house is a little
bigger so they gave you a lot of hints
there and when i was talking about
it plays on the fear of what you have to
face that one day you'll get to this
level
that was shown so effectively with the
reactions bella heath go to place sam
is seeing looking at these post-it notes
the post-it notes concept was brilliant
it was perfect
uh original way to show a horror
sequence and getting information and
her seeing like the grandma reminding
her of her own name and then
you see sansa is like what and it's
scary because it's confirming how sick
the grandma is
she's facing that and it's kind of just
showing you
her realizing where the brain can
actually go and that one day she will
probably get to that level
it's an impending doom for all of us and
it really did a good job too
of showing sam now knocking on the walls
and then the grandma and the mother
hearing it
so it's kind of giving you now like you
can connect the beginning when they
first heard knocking that that was
actually the grandma so they did a good
job revealing that and
i really love this sequence here when
the grandma's in the bathtub
it gets real full-on just disturbing
visual horror here with her stabbing
herself the mom's seeing that
but it's cutting between really smoothly
this claustrophobic
feeling of sam going down this hallway
because the walls just get tighter
and tighter and there's some really cool
camera tilts and then sam
going through walls and falling over and
it makes you have that exciting feeling
as an audience member just watching and
being like how did they film this it's
very impressive and it really comes to
that
horrific visual payoff you were waiting
for that with the grandma crawling on
the floor and chasing them through the
hallway
and then them just pushing through this
wall for the mantle place
leading to some really amazing acting
here i have to say
again by emily mortimer on her face when
she has to take down her own mother with
the pipe but then
when sam's ready to run out and realizes
oh my god this is just an evil spirit
possessing her
she even says outside this isn't grandma
but the mom realizes there is a part of
her still there
and feels bad and stays and you see that
emily mortimer
just literally has to betray so much on
her face in one scene where there's fear
but then there's regret
guilt feeling sorry and that's shown
brilliantly by the director here with
that post-it note
with her reminding herself the grandma
that she's loved
wow that really hit and then to have
k look at the window and then she's
connecting it now
seeing the black mold come there and see
where this kind of
came from in that old outhouse she's
always had premonitions about in her
nightmares really impressive stuff
and it leads to the best scene of the
movie which is the final scene
and that's one of my favorite things
when a movie closes on its best scene
it's the best feeling because that's
what you're leaving the movie on you
kind of get
of why i was on this journey in the
first place and you get your amazing
emotional payoff
this beautiful moment that i think will
go down in
history of film if you're going to take
one thing away from this film
it's that last five minutes with kay
bringing her grandma on the bed
and her peeling the skin off seeing the
full decay happen now
kissing the forehead it's creepy it's
eerie
and it's powerful and it's sad and if
you've had experience again
watching a parent you know going on
their way out here
you'll really feel this scene
emotionally and because it's so creepy
and like hard to watch
isn't that hard at its best where it has
both of those combined and it was a
perfect choice to have sam come into the
bedroom here
lining the three of these generations of
women
up and seeing it as you go
as you get older and we all again hit
this impending doom but
you see that the mother finally came
around is just there for her mother
and i thought it was brilliant that you
had this
sam character again who's the more naive
one always has some hope in her face
face the reality now not just her
grandma but the mom
the next line of the generation of this
family
is starting to decay and get a little
black mold on her skin
and it's coming for you it's coming for
your mother it's coming from your
grandma
she's already vindicated so it really is
that
haunting terror we all have as we age
and it perfectly closes the last shot of
the window
and the curse that has bestowed this
house and decay
but that curse is true in real life of
just
death so overall i'm giving this one a
9.2
i really enjoyed it i will suggest if
you've only watched it once this is
another one i say this a lot but it's so
important a lot of with
horror movies now too it's you gotta
really watch him twice to really
appreciate it and
that's because once you get the full
picture of why
you watch what you watch the first time
then when you watch it the second time
you enjoy every scene more so i think
it's just a deep film
and you'll appreciate you'll applaud it
more you'll get why it was such a slow
burn maybe the first hour when you see
it again and it won't feel like a slow
burn the second time i promise you that
so
make sure to watch it twice but maybe
you felt differently as a whole let me
know
maybe you agree with me i'd love to hear
your thoughts comment below i read every
comment try to respond as many as i can
and please make sure to subscribe i do a
bunch of other movie reviews
tv reviews i also do celebrity
interviews you don't want to miss any of
those
and please follow me at steven1 on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time